of some so all of a sudden it always
started me corner with the survey of a
recent survey make my hands of the
students file of questions who
find this same video 1 who plays it
who undermines studied was born to negotiate on the
beauty side done  that they were lively to you
that he spoke it better and then at the same
time all opposed to the questions that we
are that they know or think and of
content what that question asked me
which complicated mali for example  who
recognize themselves kriyolio madiot
higher defined than that we in trio related
ask that it is more than
definite time who saïda site is dedicated
even a duo who that in the past the hosts
in intimate words in the caribbean to whom that  going to
pass when his life does not know more or
less of the prg senator with the reception or
of karim entities and then even if with that
knocked to start what like an
idiot and rubbed shoulders with us led to
troubles and to the east but how many
Occasionally
frontzeck had no experience as in
libya or change while class there to
evolve yes so for me it's my
technical level because in five
or angry goes up as and who quoted
high and it starts macro public
listen yes yes via went especially under
different dimensions which is important
for class of a sudden and Creole white hats
and this great Creole report to the
implants divine cited a report going
with the a5 development therefore this observation
but measured to watch out for the middle of everything